[Music]
that's cardi B sharing an unreleased
song she wrote about her daughter
culture when she was pregnant
the lyrics are tender sweet and
emotional the 27 year old rapper shared
snippets of the personal rap on her
Instagram story on Mother's Day
recognize the beat well it's a sample
from Eve's 1999 hit love is blind cardi
is at home in quarantine
amid the pandemic but that didn't stop
the proud mama and her family berating
Mother's Day to the fullest
the mommy
I got a kiss please cardi spent the day
with her man offset and one-year-old
daughter culture there were balloons
flowers like thousands of flowers these
blouses for me I guess they're not mine
Oh more's their culture and of course
designer bag swag check out baby culture
opening her mom's orange Hermes box
budget you got that for me you got that
for mommy thank you thank you thank you
I wanna G
the big reveal not one but two Hermes
purses one neon yellow and one teal
seems like cardi loved her special
celebration she shared this video in bed
with a 429 a.m. time stamp she said she
had the best day cardi has always been
candid about motherhood with et love I
think she's just Lord whoever gives her
the milk here's what she told us last
year about her experience as a mama so
far what does it mean to be a mother
like Lovejoy it's a switch know what I'm
saying they're like automatic smile
right it's automatic worried sad you
know what I'm saying like I said you
know my baby had a cold and I never felt
like like so sad and I wanted to cry and
so worried like I just
oh god it's crazy
[Music]